great
okay so here we go i'll i'll start off
so
um welcome to more of the
wolfram technology conference um
we we i started yesterday um
giving a talk on the wall from compiler
and progress and some of the things that
that we can do
um mark zephroniu gave a very nice talk
on um some of the arithmetic systems and
sort of optimization um features and
things that we had
and um today i was going to give another
talk
um looking at some uh ideas of
high performance computing with the
wolfram compiler
so i'm just going to run through some
just in case there are a few people that
weren't
at the talk yesterday who are are here
today
um just quick refresh the compiler
it's a compiler for the wolfram language
um it's a long-term project that's been
going for some time
um and it's entirely built in in the
wolfram language
and some of the things that it can do
the
fundamental thing is it converts wolfram
language code
into native machine code code that's
very close
to the hardware the metal the cpu
instructions
it uses llvm as a back end it has an
in-memory
jit compilation mechanism but it can
also generate dynamic libraries
it uses static type annotations with
type inferencing
and it's an alternative execution model
for wolfram language code so
let's just talk about performance
computing um
there is you know the fundamental thing
we need to do is to make sure that
the code we're generating is is fast
that it's
pairing well with handwritten c or c
plus plus that's compiled with
other compiler systems like gcc or clang
there are some special program
transformations that can assist
um performance computing um automatic
differentiation as an example
and then there's various technologies
that we can
take advantage of multi-core
um cpus grid computing
and gpu computing and i'm going to try
and talk a little bit about
all of these in the time that i have
available
so first i just want to talk about code
optimization
so this is automatically rewriting code
so that it's faster
it might mean that users take some
dishes
decisions to relax
the requirements sort of turning off
safety measures
that sometimes can be beneficial and it
might also mean targeting
special tools libraries and hardware
and just to reiterate the basic
pipeline of the compiler is that we have
a wolfram language
phase of it where we we start with
language code
and we generate an intermediate
representation
and then we process the intermediate
representation
with various transformations then we
hand it over we generate
an llvm intermediate representation
that does more work and generates
machine code
so the wolfram intermediate
representation is pretty close
to the native machine code of of the
platform
but it has some differences so one
difference it has
type markup in it that's quite useful
for figuring out intent
and verifying the code and again and
then there's another
detail and i'm this is much probably too
technical
to to go to in the moment but it's
written in a certain way
that has some important mathematical
properties
um that make it very suitable for
transformations
and and you know such like and so
in the sort of optimization
the the some of the standard techniques
that are done
things like constant propagation
constant evaluation
eliminating copies eliminating code and
branches
and inlining code and a lot of the
optimizations that we do these get run
over and over again
trying to reach sort of optimal
code now we have a few
transformations there's potential for
optimizations and work that's special
to the wall from language that's based
on knowledge of the wolfram language
like fusing operations or avoiding
data copying based upon wolfram language
semantics
and then there are other things that are
more general lower level
um transformations that llvm
is very good at and there's a lot of
functionality
in llvm for doing things like that
there's a lot of loop
work so lifting things out of loops
eliminating loops
um and this is super important because
even though actually the loops
run quite fast they interfere with an
even
lower level of the cpu because they
interfere with
pipelining of instructions so when you
hit loops and branches
that that can cause problems
with optimal code so if they can be
eliminated by analysis of code
that's that's that's going to be quite
useful
um
right oh there's just a quick question
about the new intel mac
it's already working so we we we have
the compiler already working on the
um new rmax that's the benefit of
working with um
llvm so um we're up on
the game for that but let me just give
an example of a transformation
that's special to wolfram language
so i've defined a function and then
so in this function what's been written
is
i've got you know one list and i'm
adding it to another list
so in the and this is done actually
at the ast the syntax tree level
is it's actually done the it's realized
that i'm adding
two lists that have the same dimensions
and so it's eliminated them and it's
turned them into one list and actually
this is
this makes a huge um improvement in
timing we don't have to
bother make you know making a list is
kind of expensive or something
so that's that's that's type of a
performance um
transformation there's another
type of transformations that involve
relaxing
requirements of the um system
so um you can avoid validating
we both mark and i showed some examples
of this avoiding
validated arithmetic or abort handling
things like that
and just remember that a lot of special
hardware like gpus
they already are relaxing your
requirements they're they're running in
a
different arithmetic model than you
would get
from just the sort of you know precise
um
cpu operation so
now um i'm going to look a little bit at
using um some multi-core
hpu so what this is doing is this is
this is still an experimental thing but
this is using
concurrent code running in multiple
threads and these are some tools that
we've been developing
um to make use of um
a technology that's that's commonly
supported
um that's that's that's that's called
omp
and one of the key things
a couple key things to mention is that
running
code in concurrent current code in
multiple threads
with uncompiled interpreted code is
simply not possible this is code not
not like individual functions but
writing wolf and language code that runs
concurrently is is is
is not possible with the interpreted
code
and these new tools people ask about
this
that they have a lot more flexibility
than the old
parallelization option i'll try to show
you some of this
so here are some of the things we have
so we have for example
a parallel map and we start out with a
list
and we partition it and work on
individual parts of it
in in threads and then populate the
result
we wait for everything to complete and
then then we can finish and this is
all on one machine and so we have like
this compiled
parallel compiled map and we can um
launch this so some of the compilations
are a little bit
slow but they get faster as the time
goes on
[Music]
and then
right so there we go and
so this i'm giving this is like a 100
million
data elements and we can process this in
um you can see how you know the speed of
see that this is that this is running at
so now i'm generating
a sequential version and on the same
data set
it's running um you know quite
significantly
um so i've got eight calls on my machine
so that's that's this is getting up to
the sort of
optimal speed that that that we might
have
um from this and just to give another
if i come and run i need to take a
function here and i run this
and actually i'm running this on i'm
taking only
a hundredth of the so really you should
multiply this number by
a hundred so the the the this is
actually running in the old compiler
it's it's it's going to be
so this is gone you know very
significantly faster
right let's have a look um
right apparel fault you're getting some
slightly more technical questions
um
having an inquiry right there's
a question i'm just answering some
questions as we go along there's a
question about a cuda replacement for
mac os
use with the um machine learning
modeling
um that's that's a question i mean there
are alternatives to cuda on
macs so the the basic problem there is
that apple
and nvidia have no um working
relationship and so there's no
um utility of any nvidia hardware or
cuda programming
on on macs you need linux or windows for
that
i believe that the underlying mxnet
the machine learning framework is pretty
also
tied into cuda so at the moment there's
not a good
solution to that are there good
tutorials for writing parallel compiled
code
some books have guides but not nearly
into this depth
um yes i think i think the answer there
is that we
we should be the these tools are still
not quite the prime time but i'm a big
believer in writing
um tutorials and uh and if people are
happy to contribute to the effort that's
that's that's fantastic um so there's
all sorts of ways of
of contributing with this and that's
that's that's really useful
right let's talk about a parallel fold
so this is um
basically you have a a list and then you
partition it
and you do work on the um individual
parts
and then you do reductions you do might
do several stages of reductions
till you get a result so this is um
you can sort of set this up running so
this is a bit like
fold over um
a data set and um
then we run this and
again we get we get you know a nice nice
accelerations
for this again the sequential version
is running quite a bit
quite quite quite a bit slower so we're
also getting the same answer which which
obviously is um attractive
um here's another construct this is a
parallel
table and this
is um runs
so we give it a small input but what's
quite useful is to give
a a large large input and again this
table instruction
we're getting you know
um some quite quite quite quite nice
accelerations in this
so one of the things that works quite
well with these
parallel um constructs is we're making a
big suite of different styles of
parallel constructs without
where you know you don't have to worry
about the
the actual details and and i thought
this might be an interesting just to
work through
some an actual example of
and this this came from some user code
that somebody sent in
and they were trying to do a mandelbrot
computation and this this was their code
so they made
a compiled function and they ran it
um very little there's a question here
about how much mathematical system is
dependent on
java um not
very little of the um
now some of the connectivity codes so
there's like a
um a toolkit for working with um
sql databases that that can use use java
um but we've been steadily working um
to to to you know not
to to to avoid that um right sorry i'm
jumping back and forth so here's the
computation and it ran in in such like
so and this actually is right right
running faster than in
12.1 now here
i'm taking the same code that i had
there
but see this has an inefficiency because
i'm
generating a table and then i'm mapping
over the table
but but really it's much better just to
put the table
inside the compiled function and then i
only have to make the data once
and so i get some you know this is this
has got a little bit
this has got a little bit faster and
sometimes it's better to run these
you can run these things sometimes they
they they they need to sort of warm up
the the underlying and all the m jit
system
now i'm going to take the same example
and i've replaced the the table with a
parallel table and
there's some piles and
um the um
right this runs so now we we're getting
like like a serious parallel
acceleration we've gone from 1.2
seconds down to 0.2 seconds
um that we've
generated yes so one of the things that
this does actually is this is fusing
there are two iterators here it actually
abuses both of them into
one iterator and does the compute does
does all of that in in parallel so
just little description on the benefits
of
this multi-core it's it's very easy
to you know set this up because your
your platform your your cp your computer
already has multiple cpus
and communication between them is is
pretty fast it's the speed of
you know basically memory accesses which
is in some ways you know it's
slower than retrieving from from cpu
crashes
there's no grid communi you know no grid
launching
there are still some issues that we have
to work through of how to propagate
errors with exceptions
and and memory management that we're
still resolving and this is why this is
still
um experimental thing
um right now so someone gave
mick white gave a thumbs up for grid
launching of course that's what i'm
going to talk about now
um the grid launching is has has its use
as well
so i actually have in my i i keep a
few actually i have lots of computers
but i keep particularly linux and
mac and windows because i need to check
that things work on that
and i have a little network need to keep
an eye on the time um
so this is you know the grid so i've got
my main machine and i've got a couple of
workers
and the idea is the main machine sends
out
commands to you know the workers
and then the workers send a response
and mathematica actually comes with a
system
um where i've got you know where you can
set things up i set things up
with to launch the kernels with ssh and
actually
once i got the ssh connection working
sometimes in live there we go that's
that's all working
um it's actually quite robust and uh
um such nice i have four kernels on
um a windows machine and four kernels on
a linux machine
and i can i do parallel evaluate it
sends the same command
to everything and reaps the result so
i thought about a way to integrate this
with the compiler
so the compiler has a mechanism for
making dynamic libraries
so what you do is once per machine
you send a command to one one cpu on
that machine each machine
to compile some code and make a library
for that code and then each
on the machine each kernel then loads
each cpu loads
back that library and so i thought that
was an interesting workflow
and i wrote i wrote some code that
so we can set that up and so we
initialize
the system and so the main kernels these
are the
kernels that are going to do the
compilations
and so now what i'm going to do is
i do this um
so this is contacting each one kernel on
each machine
to create a library and so it has to
initialize
and then it loads that library into each
of the kernels
and i can you know this is just like
xbox one
um one of the things i set up which
now hang on
sometimes i hit the wrong key right was
i set this up so this the name of the
function is defined on each
worker but it's not defined in the main
system
and that's quite useful and there's a
common snap you know
it can be a snapu in the
um parallel toolkit in the
you send a command it doesn't actually
execute remotely it comes back and then
executes
locally so it looks like you've got the
right answer but it didn't do what you
intended
now i'm going to show this isn't a
totally exciting
example but this is some sort of monte
carlo
computation so i'm generating
you know a random number and
i'm going to um
then iterate
do a number of iterations um
to you know see if it's
you know basically computing pi so if
the result
is is is less than one it's
based upon you know the area of a circle
then i
increment the counter otherwise i don't
and i'm using the
nest operation so so i've done the
um computation there and then i've sent
to the workers i've sent the um
um
result coming back there um so
this is i'm okay right right so i'm
getting a
question maybe i might answer
that well well basically the
the plus the the reduction function you
do
the parallel okay i'll have to go so
maybe i'll answer that question at the
end i don't want to
run out of time so so doing this
computation it's slightly better to do
it in with the parallel submit
functionality
so what this does is this is a little
bit more asynchronous
um and so here i've submitted a number
of
jobs and then it's waiting for all for
everything to come back
so this this is another quite nice way
of using the compiler
with the grid technology and just
going into the grid technology um
it's it's good for scaling to very large
systems
it's it's good where the you know the
jobs run
very independently so if there's a
problem with one of them
it doesn't bring everything down and
you know mathematica has quite a lot of
built-in functionality for working with
these
ad hoc grids so that's that's that's
kind of an interesting
um functionality right so
let's come and look at another hpc
functionality and this is something this
is
transforming programs this is
automatic differentiation and um
it's a bit like symbolic computation
but because of those technical details
it's it's very suitable for hbc
and also for technical reasons it fits
very well with this intermediate form
of the compiler and so here
what we do is we take a a function
and what we're doing is we're
it it compiles it into this sort of
intermediate form
and then it does transformations on it
and it generates a new function
that um will return
the value of the function and
the derivative and and it's
it's a projection of of the jacobian
it's really
more suited to sort of very large
multivariate systems where
you've you've got thousands of input
variables rather than just
one but i i did this just with one
um just because it's slightly easier to
sort of see what's what's happening
and so now i'm going to compute the
derivative
for a range of inputs and we can see
that actually we've got
quite a good rendition of the result
now this was slightly cheating because
the function i had here was just a
an elementary function and so it you
know it
it knows how to to differentiate that
but here's
here's an example that's slightly more
unusual
i'm going to take a series expansion
and generate a function and compile that
and so this this shows me so it's not a
bad
i've got nine terms in the series of
course if we go a little bit further on
then this let's talk to the
analysts and they'll tell us you know
what what the range of convergence of
this
series is um and just out of
fyi this is the again this could
probably be written in some more
efficient um
form but this is showing what the what
the function actually
um actually is so now what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take that function
which is just written as a you know
sequence of
elementary functions and i'm going to
different i've differentiated them
differentiated it and now i'm going to
do
the um look at the output so the
again just fyi the output
is going to be um
right so it says you know if if the
input is
zero then the output is one and the
derivative is one
and so here's the um
differentiated results so this is
actually from a version a purely
elementary thing it's able to to
the the the differential quite
quite effectively and there's other
technical benefits is actually computing
the
um value and the derivatives all in one
computation so it can share um
various you know optimizations and
things in in the middle
so this is um you know very relevant for
hpc
many computational problems need
accurate
if they've got more accurate derivatives
they'll be able to generate a
a result it's a bit dumb in
with the univariate case it's good to to
see it um
but it gets particularly beneficial with
multivariate um
functions right now let's talk a little
bit about gpu programming
um so
just quick run down uh gpu programming
is using
graphical programming units for general
programming
and typically gpus
offer they have huge numbers
of cpus but the cpus are not quite as
flexible i mean they're during complete
and everything but they're not quite as
flexible
as um the cpu on your
um you know machine nonetheless they can
be used for certain types of
um computations and they can give
massive accelerations they're
non-trivial to set up and the code that
runs on them is subject to
incredible constraints which also makes
them non-trivial
the um a particularly popular gpu system
is known as cuda which is the
programming language the
system that runs on nvidia hardware and
you have to keep
going fast and run out of time and it
has has this little model you have your
cpu
and you offload the data and it goes
through this sort of complicated you
you copy data you run the kernel on the
um gpu and then you copy the data back
so we have a thing called cuda link
that's bundled with the use
the wolfram language for a long time but
now we're starting i'm not going to
evaluate these to build um
a link based on the compiler to
um nvidia tools so we can just since the
um programming language for
you know nvidia provider c interface
it's very
easy to set up compiler bindings and
it's the same game plan as
you know what we did with omp and things
like that
and so we just make bindings to these
and then we could write functions and
compile them
and they run in the same way as if they
were being called from c
plus plus but since they're integrated
with the rebel system
of of uh you know wolfram language
they're very convenient
so then we need to generate a
cuda kernel um this is the thing that
executes and so you
typically you write something that looks
like this but what's what's new now is
that we can generate
convert this do code generation on this
but
we can generate the um ptx that the
language that actually runs on the gpu
so with this we've gone from wall from
language a wolfram language
specification to something that executes
on the gpu
then we need to use this we need a
driver program and
don't need to look at all this but this
is doing the copying we can compile that
and then we can execute it so i've
used here a
numeric array input i
pass this driver the the program
and the inputs and we get back the
result
so that's um the
idea is that we're looking to integrate
the cuda link with the compiler
and this should significantly lower the
barrier for working with
um gpus and and be
feasible to do this with other um
other um systems um and this is kind of
a nice interactive new workflow is that
you can prototype
gpu work interactively and then compile
it all to and
combine it all into one function and
compile it
and i think i'm just about out of time
so i'm going to
give a summary so i looked at some
issues of performance computing
possibilities from the wolfram compiler
um
i looked at code optimization issues
some some multi-core computation grid
computing
automatic differentiation and gpu
programming and again i'll just
reiterate that we have a lot of
opportunities for developers interns um
various flexible ways so get in touch
with us if you're interested in
coming to um work on this so i'll just
answer a couple of questions that that
came in i will share the
notebook out at the end um
the um yes it's possible to generate
standalone
um executables um you you
and if you have them you you might or
might not need the wolfram engine
depending what your code
does but it's entirely possible to make
things that run
entirely independently of the wolfram
engine the gpu compilation does not
require
mvcc it just it requires the
cuda toolkit because that has some
bindings some llvm bindings
but it's purely based upon um llvm
so it's it's not running the um the the
nvidia compiler and then there was a
question about
uh if bold is associative right so what
you're paralyzing
is i'll just go back and try and show
you how this
is working um it's
the there's a red fold actually
you can think of fold as here's the fold
there's actually or maybe i'll just
show this so in fold you do something
like
you have a function that takes um
one argument that's the
the so in fact what you're doing is
you you have like a reduce function
and a map function
this is kind of another way of thinking
about
um bold you see so so
the this is this is plus
in in in here um so
but and so what you're you're doing is
you're you're
assuming that the um the the reduce
function can be run
multiple times so so you have some
constraints
upon the type of the reduce function
um but again this is a compiler so we
know the
um um
answer that so you you you have
knowledge
from from the compiler about the the the
details of of your functions
so since you allow tying in cuda yes
i think there'd be a lot of
possibilities for tying in some
other um toolkits and things like that
that the compiler is incredibly useful
for making
very performant um interactions with
other technologies
[Music]
right so there's a question about mxnet
and compiling so it can run train
without mxnet
um i that's a slightly technical
question i'm not an
expert in this and mxnet has an awful
lot of machinery and
types and things that are quite
convenient um
so but and the the automatic
differentiation is itself useful for
um mxnet um you know so that's that's
all
um especially if you want to write your
own layers or your own
additions to things and that's that's
that's that's that's that's quite useful
i tried generating shared object was not
running by calling the library
um directly
um i'm not quite sure what that question
means so um
but i think i should probably wrap up
because people need to get onto
other talks and keep sending questions
and
we can we can answer this but thank you
very much thank you
you